bonjour antoine heureuse de vous
retrouver dans cette matinale alors
dernier volet de cette série sur les
gilet jaune gilet jaune de laisser à vie
blessé en tout cas pendant ces
manifestations
vous avez rencontré l'avocat david lee
moss keane qui accompagnent certains
d'entre eux dites nous en plus sur votre
enquête
bonjour olivier bon genre magali alors
david libeskind il représente plusieurs
victimes d'utilisation illégitime de la
force ou d'accident de maintien de
l'ordre ils attendent notamment aidé
jérôme rodriguez lorsqu'il a été blessé
au tout début de son affaire mais reste
également très en contact au contact du
mouvement des gilet jaune il reste un
grand soutien pour eux pour lui une
partie du problème vient du manque du
manque de considération de la part des
politiques et des donneurs d'ordre qui à
son sens devrait reconnaître leurs torts
dans ces affaires qui ont donné lieu à
des blessures très graves puisque ces
personnes qui sont handicapés à vie
afin de permettre aux victimes de
commencer à se réparer sur le plan
psychologique
écoutons ce qu'il avait à l'audience
le fait que les daims reconnaissent en
fait il a fauté dans l'exercice des
missions de
de maintiennent leur public et ça en
fait la plupart des personnes qui ont
été blessés ou mutilés le réclament mais
le pire c'est quand même pas d'excusé
aucune excuse publique est en train de
caler sa vision du rôle de la justice et
de l'igpn dans ces affaires alors c'est
la deuxième chose dont on a parlé avec
david lieb et sliti il m'a expliqué qu'à
son sens il y avait deux freins
importants au sentiment de justice pour
les liégeois qui ont été gravement
blessés tout d'abord le temps judiciaire
est long et voir ces dossiers déboucher
sur des suites dans les deux à trois ans
après la blessure ça reste un délai
relativement normale à son sens compte
tenu du manque d'effectifs dans
l'institution judiciaire
par ailleurs ils pointent donc en
deuxième frein le manque d'indépendance
de l'igpn vis-à-vis de la police
nationale et il plaide pour une réforme
totale de ce système d'inspection
merci beaucoup antoine on va retrouver
évidemment plus en longueur
toutes vos enquêtes que l'on a diffusé
donc cette semaine dans la matinale
d'ayrté france série enquête signée
antoine wattel gilet jaune
blessé à vue merci beaucoup